so i made a video a while ago
and men over fifty were commenting
the type of women that they were interested in dating
and i've compiled the list which is kind of interesting
and i'm sure women do the same thing
but men you contradict each other quite a bit
a lot of men over fifty
said that they wanted much younger women
however a lot of men said
they wanted women who are emotionally mature
with years comes age
but also maturity number two
men said that they liked women who are very active however
they also said they didn't want a woman who was too busy
a lot of comments were about women's physicality
they wanted a woman who is trim
beautiful fashionable
but also somebody who didn't spend too much time
effort or money on their looks
there were a lot of comments about women being independent
i think specifically financially independent
however they wanted a woman who also needed them
and also they wanted woman who was spontaneous and fun
yet consistent
i'm sure women are the same way
but it seems like there's a whole lot of contradictions in
the type of women that the men over fifty want